[Applaudissements]
bonsoir les enfants patron ne faisons
pas trop de bruit mais pourquoi nounours
nicolas et pimprenelle dorment déjà nous
nous avons les sucres veut ni d'oiseaux
tout près de la fenêtre de nos deux
petits amis hier soir et à l'art
nounours
peut être bien que les parents oiseaux
sont revenus les lorrains eux dans leur
mais il ne faut pas les effrayer
tu as raison bonne échelle au hockey
vraiment parents oiseaux ils sont pas
venus bonsoir les enfants vous savez
nous annoncent aux petits as tu peux
parler normalement tu sais nous jugeons
pas venu les one you on s'est fait
plusieurs fois cette nuit mais pas mais
je n'ai pas alors on a mis du co2 sur
les yeux pour qu'il soit bien au chaud
ouais mais nous on la preuve re le
pauvre petit tu ne reprendra pas laisser
comme ça la fenêtre grande ouverte toute
la nuit
quel sort dont tu sais même nous il vaut
mieux qu'il remporte avec toi ce qu'ils
nient je le poserait sur un arbre dans
la forêt c'est bien la casse hier que je
le prends et moi je ferme ma fenêtre à
ta santé
mon petit dico la wii iata prône l on va
s'coucher les petits frères alors les
enfants
on est couché bien au chaud oui on en a
vu dormir mais toi prends bien soin du
team i où il m'est cher petit bonne nuit
faire mon bien les pompiers
oh
au soir papa ou maman ge
j'ai éteint les lumières
heureux chez les petits
ils ont enfoncé
j'ouvre la fenêtre je sens de lui
le jean 100 pts 2
sont endormis
je reprends bonus
le
je bonne
au chômage
nicolas a pas
je
outil à dos
bonne nuit les enfants
n'oubliez pas de faire votre toilette de
bien vous laver les dents embrasser bien
fort vos parents le feu deux bourgs
en route mans gros nounours en route
alors vite porté ce joli petit dans la
forêt pour que les petits oiseaux
viennent dormir dedans
bonne nuit adobe
oh
à
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]